look at this
this video is composed of 50 jokes from
nerdfighters like you two drums in a
symbol walk off a cliff but um
billy was a chemist's son but now he is
no more what he thought was h2o was
h2so4
there are two muffins in an oven one
says man it is hot in here and the other
one says
holy crap a talking muffin a child comes
up to his dad and asks daddy is god a
man or a woman
god is both is god black or white god is
both
is god michael jackson what's the
difference between neil armstrong and
michael jackson neil armstrong
walked on the moon and michael jackson
is crazy why do ducks have web
feet to stomp out fires
why do elephants have flat feet to stomp
out the burning ducks how do you kill an
elephant
with an elephant gun how do you kill a
blue elf with an elephant gum with a
blue elephant gun how do you kill a red
elephant ah with a red elephant gun
oh you choke it until it's blue and then
you shoot it with a blue elephant gun
how do you kill the purple elephant
you choke it until it's blue and then
you shoot it with a blue elephant gun oh
my god there is no such thing as a
purple elephant
why is six so afraid of seven uh because
seven eight nine what's brown and sticky
uh stick what do christmas and the cat
in the desert have in common
sandy claws does snoop dogg ever need an
umbrella for drizzle
there are 10 types of people in the
world those who know binary and those
who don't man it smells like
up dog in here what's up dog nothing
what about you the square root of
negative one and pi are having an
argument
after much discussion the square root of
negative one shouts at pi please would
you just be rational
pi responds get real how much did the
pirate pay to get his ears pierced a
buccaneer
the pirates say when he got a steering
wheel stuck on his pants oh it's driving
me nuts
a kid just like a pirate for halloween
knocks on this lady's door oh aren't you
a cute little pirate but where are your
buccaneers
under my bucking hat so there's this
pirate and he's walking around he's
wearing a paper towel for a hat
and so i asked him what's with a paper
towel ah i got a bounty on my head
why couldn't the little pirate go to see
the movie because it had too much booty
and was raped r why does it take pirates
so long to learn the alphabet cause they
could spend years at sea why don't
dinosaurs talk
because they're dead how do you make a
handkerchief dance you put a little
boogie in it
how to avoid bad knock knock jokes knock
knock uh
come in what do politicians in sperm
have in common
every 500 or 600 million have a chance
of becoming a human grasshopper walks
into a bar bartender says hey we got a
drink named after you brow supper says
ah you got a drink named larry one atom
says to the other atom holy crap i just
lost an electron
are you sure yes i'm positive why did
the monkey fall out of the tree
because it was dead or whether the
second monkey followed the tree because
it was stapled to the first monkey
but why did the third monkey fall out of
the tree peer pressure i wish to die
peacefully in my sleep
like my grandfather not panicking like
his passengers
did you hear about that guy who got the
entire left half of his body cut off
yeah but he's all right now but is the
relationship between a pumpkin's
circumference and its radius pumpkin pie
why don't oysters give to charity well
because they're shellfish
what are the two dirtiest animals in the
farm yard
brown chicken brown cow i don't believe
i just did that
where does the king keep his armies in
his sleevies
how many surrealists does it take to
change a light bulb
fish how many psychologists does it take
to do a light bulb just one but the
light bulb has to want to change
what did the bear say to the other bear
when they finished eating the clown did
he taste funny to you
what do you get when you mix an agnostic
and dyslexic and an insomniac
a dude who sits up all night wondering
whether or not there is a dog
what do you call a female sex change an
antidictomy what do you call a male sex
change
lapidophamy two fischer in a tank one
fish says to the other fish do you know
how to drive this thing what kind of
cheese just isn't yours nacho cheese
why is the math book so sad but had a
lot of problems what if the difference
between a writer and a park bench a park
bench can
support a family john i'm just kidding
that was 50 jokes i'll see you later
leave your favorite jokes in the
comments i kind of want to make another
one of these